good morning John it's Monday despite
the fact that I Drive a lot this weekend
and we've been doing all these epic
travel vlogs which I think totally part
of the future of vlogging I'm not going
to do that today I just got home it is 7
o'clock I need to make a video now and I
need to do it fast and I don't exactly
know what I'm gonna do it about go get
to work buddy
harden me stop stalling and start being
interesting I would love to do you have
some suggestions dude this is your job
now you know how to do this do it right
okay a study published today has
determined that young girls are hitting
puberty earlier or at least their
breasts are developing earlier I find
this disturbing for two very different
reasons one because obviously something
about the way that we live our lives is
affecting all our children hormonal eat
and do because it means that there are
people in the world who study young
girl's breasts for a living excellent
news stories are good
now here's with another one I have
totally got another one Wyclef Jean is
running for president in Haiti his
strength apparently is that he's not a
politician and he doesn't know anything
about the politics of Haiti that is his
strength and it's all well and good say
I am NOT a politics tent you want the
guy who's fixing your car to be a
mechanic right
and if he's fixing a Toyota you want him
to have a metric socket set likewise it
would be nice if Wyclef Jean spoke
French which is the language that he
shouldn't speak I mean how are you
supposed to run a country if you can't
talk to people okay news is getting old
move on to the next thing I've got more
news there's this Google's Verizon thing
no no time for it everyone is getting
bored tell them something embarrassing
about yourself from the past that you
can give some kind of inspirational note
about afterward okay
um when I was in Middle School a really
cool kid came up to me and he said do
you want to join the pin 15 club we're
all in the pin 15 club and I was wearing
you know I was I was significantly
suspicious but you know I really wanted
to be accepted and to anything it didn't
matter what it was I needed the
acceptance and so of course I said yes
and he pulled out his sharpie and to
join the pen15 Club you just get pen 15
written on your hand p.e and oh I messed
up I'm not good at this let's do it on
our arm instead and it looks like it
says penis it was a horrifying
experience horrifying enough that
apparently I still remember it nearly 20
later but you know what I'm proud to be
in the pen15 Club and anybody else who's
ever been in the pen15 Club we're in the
pen15 Club together I came through that
extremely moderate amount of adversity
stronger than I was before because I can
and must be myself and some people may
not like the person that I am I can
never let that change pen15 Club for the
win oh my god you are such a nerd okay
okay I know what to do next you don't
have to do anything for this part worse
location Jew [ __ ] in chapatti yo yo
Egypt got my Obama judge on your long
tongue shape it's no kissing weight on
something and shall you dump ETF what
was that I have no idea no seriously
what was that seriously I have no idea I
just found it on the Internet it's just
an internet thing move on
ah this guy is weird and you would be
nothing without me so yeah now give
everybody an update on what's going on
with you and nerdfighter area and
everything and then finish up okay I
shall do that number one toke eternity
to these best to make the vlogbrothers
stay and number 81 but of course we did
not and we are now 83rd having been
passed by Toby Turner and the amazing
Freddie Wong also I sang a little song
with Andrew Gregory of the Gregory
Brothers about a bedroom intruder you
can go check that out and the tumblr fvn
nerdfighters now has 5000 followers and
you should follow them too if you aren't
already because then you can find
amazing things like this by the way John
you're a meme John we'll see young women
today
you
so yeah it's going to be hard to wash
off